good morning Hank it's Wednesday Who am
I kidding you're not watching this
you're in Haiti Hank I'm really grateful
to you for being the noble brother who
goes out there on the frontlines to
decrease worldsuck
because that means that I can stay in my
basement why am I still talking to him
he's not watching we are free from the
tyranny of Hank
okay nerdfighters this morning I went to
your pants and asked for some questions
and now here are some answers after
reading with me for Alaska I wonder if
you thought about what you want your
last words to be before you die not at
all to paraphrase the great John
Barrymore dying is the last thing I
would ever do did you have any nicknames
as a teenager yeah one time I said that
Christian Slater never made a bad movie
and thereafter a lot of my friends
called me cuffs
dandy lions or dandy lions Oh dandy
Lions for sure do you know what happens
if you wish on a dandy lion he eats you
by the way the dandy Lions really good
band name it's tax time again any
fishing boat proceeds this year no
stupid fishing boats always refusing to
give me proceeds when's your new book
coming out in almost exactly one year
what's it about oh it's about these two
teenage cancer survivors who are both
obsessed with this reclusive novelist
but it's also about a bunch of other
things like Swedish hip-hop and you know
the meaning of life and stuff is it
really narrated by a girl yes hazel
what's the title I don't know I change
you like every day and they all suck do
you have any good titles if you have any
good titles please leave them in
comments what is the biggest obstacle in
your opinion to getting started as a
professional writer essentially the
world contains a lot of books and not
that many people who are willing to pay
to read them can you say the alphabet
backwards
zyx w no are you friends with liver Bray
have you read any of her books
yes I'm friends with Libba Bray and I've
read all of her books including beauty
queens which isn't even out yet did you
know that liver brain just broke both of
her elbows I realize that sounds like a
euphemism for being pregnant with twins
or something but seriously liver brain
just broke both of her elbows and I'm
not even that surprised about it to be
honest like if you told me John one of
your friends just broke both of her
elbows I would be like I bet it was
libel you never hear about people like
Sarah Dessen breaking both of their
elbows it just doesn't have the poor
liver
anyway her new book is amazing you
should pre-order it link in the
doobly-doo I didn't end up writing a
desert island novel because you know
after Webbys I don't have to will you
ever walk alone
so if I didn't know this was a Liverpool
scarf I might think I was dressing up as
Walden for Christmas you don't dress up
for Christmas green hey is your phone
number secretly inserted into Looking
for Alaska yeah that used to be my phone
number I mean when I wrote Looking for
Alaska
I didn't think more than about nine
people would read it you know so yes I
did put my phone number in it I have a
message for the person who has that
phone number now
sorry favorite old-school video game
pong because I like video games that are
like life--and pong just keeps getting
harder until you die have you ever been
arrested no coffee or tea coffee I'm
hiding from the people if you could
would you probably nah let's face it I'm
not the kind of guy who does Hank thank
you for going to Haiti we look forward
to the most amazing thoughts from places
videos ever and I will see you on Friday
when I upload the video that you already
made but I will really see you on I'm so
bad at this Wednesday seems so far away